Thanks for watching!
If you liked this video, please subscribe to my channel and give it a thumbs up!
I am going to transition us into a time of worship, normally if we were live this would
be a prayer, but since I pre-record these videos I have found that it is more authentic
if I share with you something that is speaking to me, usually it is a passage or a poem.
A couple weeks ago if you were here I read from a section of Isaiah 58, Isaiah 58 is
one of my favorite chapters in the entire Bible, it is kind of like my North Star in
terms of my faith.
Tonight I actually have a poem for us and if you are familiar with Isaiah 58 at all
or you remember what I read, Isaiah 58 talks about true worship, it starts the passage
by saying what isn't true worship, what isn't life giving and then it ends into what actual
worship looks like, what it feels like, the feet behind worship.
I have a poem this evening that very much reminds me of the spirit of Isaiah 58 in many
many ways.
I will go ahead and tell you that it very much resembles the beginning of Isaiah 58,
but given the direction that I know that our service is going this evening I thought it
was very appropriate because it is about love.
Love isn't mentioned anywhere in the poem, but it is a poem about love.
So tonight I am going to read it to you, it is called Goodbye to Tolerance by Denise Levertov.
I would encourage you later on to Google this poem and read it and read Isaiah 58 and see
if you can't feel the same spirit in the two of them.
So Goodbye to Tolerance.
Genial poets, pink-faced, earnest wits, you have given the world some choice morsels.
Gobbits of language presented as one presents t-bone steak and cherries jubilee.
Goodbye, goodbye, I do not care if I never taste your fine food again.
Neutral fellows, seers of every side, tolerance, what crimes are committed in your name.
And you, good women, bakers of nicest bread, blood donors, your crumbs choke me.
I would not want a drop of your blood in me.
It is pumped by weak hearts, perfect pulses that never falter, irresponsive to nightmare reality.
It is my brothers, my sisters, whose blood spurts out and stops forever because you chose
to believe it is not your business.
Goodbye, goodbye, your poems shut their little mouths.
Your loaves grow moldy, a gulp has split the ground between us.
And you won't wait.
You're looking another way.
We shan't meet again unless you leap it.
Leaving behind the cherished worms of your dispassion, your pallid ironies,
your jovial murderous wry-humored balanced judgment.
Leap over, unbalanced, then how fanatic tears would flow and mingle for joy.
Amen.
Wow.
Guys, I am not going to pretend like that was not heavy.
The first time I heard that poem tonight, I was like, oh my gosh, I've just got to swallow
for a few minutes and digest what I've just heard, which is really what I want to encourage
all of us to do.
I'm so glad y'all are with us.
My name is Mindy.
Man, that poem is really like a prophetic word.
And Gary and me were talking earlier before the service, and he was just reminding me
how a lot of our poets are really our prophets and artists, like today's artists.
They might not have the name of prophet, but if you take a second to really look in
to what they're saying, what they're creating, and the heart behind it, and receive the word
and be challenged by it, it can be a prophecy for us to learn from, and if we allow it to
do the work.
And it reminded me of this verse in James, James 1.
I love the book of James.
It is always challenging, and I just feel like it's such a good practical handle to
read through and really remember the gospel work that needs to be happening in us, and
not just always flip to Psalms, which is kind of my easy go-to when I just want to feel
good and be inspired.
But man, then I flip over to James, and it's like, we're doing real work here.
In verse 22, it says, do not merely listen to the word, and so deceive yourselves.
Do what it says.
And there's another translation, I think, that says, be not only hearers, but doers.
And it's easy for us to hear a poem like that and just be like, whoo, that's heavy, and
then move right on by, but I just want to challenge us tonight.
I'm challenging myself to go back to that later, to digest it, to let it do its work
in me, because real religion requires self-examination, and I don't want a faith that just makes
me feel good.
I want it to do the gospel work in the world, and that's just not going to happen without
me taking a hard look in the mirror and asking myself the question, have I been the breadmaker?
Am I clinging to the things that make me comfortable instead of looking at what needs to change
to make our world a better, more loving place where Jesus is found?
So anyways, I just want us all to hold up our lives to the light and the love of the
gospel, the love of Jesus tonight.
And that requires bravery, it requires humility on our parts to admit where we get it wrong,
where we've not loved well, but man, when we're doing that together, when we're saying
what needs to change here, am I part of a problem, that is where the beauty of the gospel
starts to take root in our life and transform us from the inside out.
So I'm going to pass it off to Gary, and as he plays through the songs and as you're listening
to the worship tonight, I just want you to take heart and remember that God meets us
right where we need Him, and He gives us what we need.
So even if the work looks scary, and maybe even sometimes we find a fence in it, we find
the love of Jesus there, and He makes us strong enough to carry it out.
So Gary, it's all yours.
Thank you, Mindy.
All right, guys.
When darkness tries to roll over my bones, when sorrow comes to steal the joy I owe,
when brokenness and pain is all I know, no, I won't be shaken, no, I won't be shaken.
My fear doesn't stand a chance when I'm standing in your love, and my fear doesn't stand a
chance when I'm standing in your love, and my fear doesn't stand a chance when I'm standing
in your love.
Shame no longer has a place to hide, and I am not a captive to the lies.
I'm not afraid to leave my past behind, no, I won't be shaken, no, I won't be shaken.
My fear doesn't stand a chance when I'm standing in your love, and my fear doesn't stand a
chance when I'm standing in your love, and my fear doesn't stand a chance when I'm standing
in your love.
There's power that can break off every chain, there's power that can empty out a grave.
There's resurrection power that can save, there's power in your name, there's power
in your name.
There's power that can break off every chain, there's power that can empty out a grave.
There's resurrection power that can save, there's power in your name, there's power
in your name.
My fear doesn't stand a chance when I'm standing in your love, and my fear doesn't stand a
chance when I'm standing in your love, and my fear doesn't stand a chance when I'm standing
in your love.
Standing in your love.
Standing on the cross.
Before I spoke a word, you were singing over me.
You have been so, so good to me.
Before I took a breath, you breathed your life in me.
You have been so, so kind to me.
Oh, the overwhelming, never-ending, reckless love of God.
Oh, it chases me down, fights till I'm found, leaves the 99.
I couldn't earn it, and I don't deserve it.
Still you give yourself away.
Oh, the overwhelming, never-ending, reckless love of God.
When I was your foe, still your love fought for me.
You have been so, so good to me.
When I felt no worth, you paid it all for me.
You have been so, so kind to me.
Oh, the overwhelming, never-ending, reckless love of God.
Oh, it chases me down, fights till I'm found, leaves the 99.
I couldn't earn it, and I don't deserve it.
Still you give yourself away.
Oh, the overwhelming, never-ending, reckless love of God.
There's no shadow you won't light up, mountain you won't climb up, coming after me.
There's no wall you won't kick down, lie you won't tear down, coming after me.
Oh, the overwhelming, never-ending, reckless love of God.
Oh, it chases me down, fights till I'm found, leaves the 99.
And I couldn't earn it, I don't deserve it.
Still you give yourself away.
Oh, the overwhelming, never-ending, reckless love of God.
Oh, how He loves us so.
Oh, how He loves us, how He loves us so.
Oh, how He loves us so, so, how He loves us, how He loves us so.
He is jealous for me.
Love's like a hurricane, I am a tree.
Bending beneath the weight of His wind and mercy.
And all of a sudden, I am unaware of these afflictions,
eclipsed by glory.
And I realize just how beautiful You are
and how great Your affections are for me.
And oh, how He loves us so.
Oh, how He loves us, how He loves us so.
He loves us, oh how He loves us.
Oh, how He loves us, oh how He loves.
Oh, how He loves us, oh how He loves us so.
So we are His portion and He is our prize.
Drawn to redemption by the grace in His eyes.
If grace is an ocean we're all sinking.
So heaven meets earth like a sloppy wet kiss.
And my heart turns violently inside of my chest.
I don't have time to maintain these regrets when I think about the way.
He loves us, oh how He loves us.
Oh, how He loves us, oh how He loves.
Jesus, thank you so much that you showed us the path to love.
May we hold our lives up to the light of your love.
And be bold enough to change.
Be bold enough to let it transform us, to do its work in us.
Would we be like a tree planted by a stream?
Let our roots go down deep.
We love you Jesus and it's in your name we pray all these things.
Amen.
Thank you Mindy.
This is beautiful.
And I just want to give a few shout outs to the comments that are out there.
Joe Brock, your last comment.
I mean I say loving the worship set today makes me miss harmonizing with you guys.
And I agree, you know.
Man, it sucks to be kind of where we are right now.
But this is what we do, you know.
We press on.
And yeah, all of you out there, Daphne, Adam, Serena.
Yeah, just thank you for tuning in.
And so, anyways, without further ado, let me introduce our speaker today.
So, it is my privilege, nay, it is my honor to introduce the one and only Josh Brock.
And so...
There's got to be more than one in the world, Gary.
Josh and I have been good friends for a few years now.
First got to know him back at New Hope Lucas.
And, you know, also he's just a neighbor.
He lives right down the street from me, him and his family, his kids.
And we have kids around the same age.
So it's just been really cool to get to know him.
And just be doing this thing together.
And yeah, I mean, one thing that I'd say about Josh is he's definitely a deeply spiritual guy, you know.
And I really got to know that.
We've been on a few guy trips together and I've kind of spent some car time with him.
If you've ever done that with anybody, you know, you get some windshield time.
You really get to kind of connect.
And yeah, Josh is a deeply spiritual dude, you know.
And so I really think you're going to enjoy what he has to share today.
And if you may or may not know, but Josh is also a firefighter.
So I just think he's like one of these guys who's got some real skin in the game, you know.
When it comes to serving, to loving well.
And, you know, he's like what I would say like a Christian, you know, with skin in the game.
That, you know, he's just...
It's not just talk.
So anyways, without any further ado, I said that twice already.
But yeah, I'll turn it over to you, Josh.
And oh, before I do that, let me pray for you.
So yeah, Father God, we thank you today for time together amongst all our friends who are just not with us in person,
who are with us spiritually, all of us tuned in.
And to those who will watch later, God, I thank you.
And I pray for Josh that you would just put your love in his heart in this moment, God,
and that he wouldn't worry about a thing, God, that he would just be himself.
And that your words and your message that you've put on him, Lord, would just flow through
and that we would be receptive, that our hearts and minds would be open, God,
and that you're going to do a good thing through Josh and in us.
So we ask that in Jesus' name.
Amen.
Wow, thanks.
Thanks for that, Gary.
I really appreciate that.
So I want to say something real quick.
This is very strange because I don't have an instrument in my hand, nor is there a microphone in front of me,
which is kind of my comfortable place when we do online church.
And then when it comes to talking, I like to see people's faces.
So this is very far out of my comfort zone as far as not being able to see faces.
And I'm literally talking to a screen that's a mirror image of me, which is odd.
So I'm going to do my best to look at the camera throughout the night so that we can make some eye contact through technology.
But yeah, I just want to say this is a new deal for me.
I've actually never spoken at a church service before.
So this has been fun, you know, preparing for this and getting to talk to you tonight.
I do truly, truly miss you guys.
I wish I was hoping that the first time I ever spoke at the table was going to be live.
But this is where we're at, right?
This is the social distancing COVID-19 thing that we're doing.
And this is a good thing because this is how we love each other by connecting through technology.
So like Gary said, my name is Josh for those that don't know me.
Oh, another thing I'm really excited about is when we do get to meet,
I feel like there's going to be so many more people that we get to connect with that we haven't met prior to having to go online.
And I'm really excited about that.
There's a lot of names that I see popping up that watch these services and that I haven't actually met in person.
And so I'm really excited about that, too.
So I think we may have a boom, you know, from when we last met.
And a lot of people, we get to hug each other's necks.
Nikki Parker, I can't wait to hug your neck because you always give me peace whenever I'm playing music.
So I'm really excited about that, too.
So tonight, I do want to give some disclaimers.
Some public service announcements.
It's funny, I've talked at different events, keynotes before.
I always give public service announcements for whatever reason.
I guess it's my creature joke before we get into the sermon.
But I went to bed last night at 1145 because I was working.
And then I got up at 130 and worked all through the night and I haven't slept.
Who knows what I'll say.
And if you walk away with anything from tonight, you will know that it was most definitely not of my power.
So just know that.
It's somebody else working on your heart and emotions.
So second public service announcement.
And this is an important one, I think.
I'm not a theologian.
I'm not a preacher.
I'm not a seminary student.
In fact, I am a seminary student dropout.
Or a Bible college dropout.
Turns out I'm allergic to seminary.
So I couldn't stay there for very long.
I had to get out and do other things.
But I say these things jokingly, but I do just want to be very clear that I am just a guy who is moved by the life and teachings of Jesus.
I think Jesus is a very significant figure in history.
I believe that he is a divine being that came to earth to show us how to live, how to be human, and how to be a part of this life and to connect with each other.
So when I was asked by the Elder team to speak in July, I was excited, a bit not perplexed, but my thoughts were, what do I have to say?
When it comes to spirituality and talking about Jesus, I fall under the category of you speak when you have something to say and you listen the rest of the time.
Like I said, I've spoken at other events in front of crowds and I love talking to people.
I love connecting with people.
In fact, I timed this message today and it was like an hour and a half, so we're going to go for a while.
I like to talk.
Just kidding.
But when it comes to talking about Jesus in a corporate context, I take pause.
I take pause because when you speak into somebody's spiritual life and their spirituality, whatever it may be, you can change their life for the good or the bad.
I think everybody has deconstructed a part of their faith at some point in their life.
And that was due to teaching that was bad teaching.
So when I was asked to speak, I gave pause and was like, what do I have to say?
This could really change somebody's life, not because I've got great things to say, but because I think Jesus lived a great life.
And I truly believe that things can be changed by looking at the life of Jesus.
Your life can be changed by looking at how he lives his life.
And I want to be an instrument that pushes that in the correct direction.
So I give pause.
I'll have to say, like I said, again, I'm just a guy who is moved by the words, teachings, just overall life of Jesus and who he was.
So tonight we are continuing on in our study of Luke.
A few weeks ago, I was given two chapters to pull from, which is like asking me to find three grains of salt in the ocean.
Right. I mean, two chapters of the Gospels, two chapters of rich Jesus language.
Right. Rich, life changing ways to live, how to be kind and loving to each other.
It's just powerful, right?
So there's so many things in these two chapters.
I mean, we had the feeding of the five, big stories, right?
Feeding of the 5,000, Jesus sends out the 70, the 70 return.
You've got the Good Samaritan.
You've got the Mary and Martha debacle, right?
She was sitting at Jesus' feet.
Martha was working.
Like so many great stories and so many things to pull from.
And I was like, man, I don't know what I'm going to pick, right?
So tonight we're going to talk about the title of my talk.
And I call it a talk.
My wife kept telling me that it's a sermon and that you're preaching.
I'm like, I don't know.
I can't bite off on that big of a...
I mean, that's a lot of weight with that, right?
So I call it a talk.
We can call it whatever we want, I guess.
But we're going to discuss, for what many centuries,
this story has been referred to as the Good Samaritan.
And to be really honest, when they said, Josh,
will you talk about something from chapters 9 and 10 in Luke,
I immediately told myself, don't discuss the Good Samaritan, right?
I typically like to pick things that haven't been overplayed, right?
You got the radio, you listen to the radio,
and there's a new song out and it's like every seventh song.
The song just repeats itself.
To eventually the point where you're just like,
I don't want to ever hear that song again, right?
And I grew up in the church.
And I remember the felt boards when I was little of the Good Samaritan.
You put the characters on the felt board,
and then the teacher told the story of the Good Samaritan.
And so just personally, I was like, don't talk about this.
Well, in typical fashion, whenever I say I'm not going to do something,
it typically turns the other way and I end up talking about it.
So I'm about to ask you a question and expect a response.
So again, it's weird, right?
Being on the screen, but the Enneagram, right?
Some of you may be familiar with the Enneagram.
I like it.
I think it's a great tool.
I'm not versed in it.
Very little work have I done in learning deeply about it.
My wife, Jo, loves the Enneagram.
She's very wise when it comes to the Enneagram.
She puts in the work and learns a lot about it.
So I hope I make you proud, Jo, when I talk about these things.
But I am a seven with a fairly strong eight wing, right?
The Enneagram's one through nine.
My number is a seven.
I've got a strong eight wing.
And so I'm going to give you a really basic rundown of what a seven is.
And all this is going to tie into how I picked the Good Samaritan,
and then we're going to dive in.
So a seven, I'm going to give you the key motivations and the key fears.
A seven's motivation is contentedness, right?
A good time, always wanting to look to the positive side of things,
satisfaction, right?
The fear of the seven is being trapped, like boxed in.
You know, don't put me in a corner.
It freaks me out.
Not physically, but just I don't like walls.
I don't like boundaries.
You know, free and to move about in my thoughts.
So that's a seven, right?
And so can I break it down?
Basically, if you said, called me and you said,
hey, Josh, let's go skydiving tomorrow.
I'd say, my answer would be,
let's rent a motorcycle with a sidecar to get us to the airstrip.
I'm pumped.
Let's go skydiving, but let's make it even more.
Let's make it even more extra, right?
So that's my personality.
How I landed on the Good Samaritan, however, comes from my eight wing.
And the eight's core motivation, and this is, again, basic,
is being like a protector.
Someone who stands up for the oppressed, protects those in their tribe.
Someone who's not afraid of confrontation
and actually kind of enjoys confrontation a little bit.
And I definitely have those pieces in my life.
So that is how I landed on this passage,
despite my initial thought of, don't do this.
And I also thought, you know, there's a lot of people
that may not have grown up in church
and may not be familiar with this story,
and it is a powerful story.
Like, oh my goodness, it was moving.
I read the passage so many times in the past few weeks.
I even downloaded an audio book of the Book of Luke, chapter 10.
The guy that read it had an English accent.
It really made the text pop.
But I don't think that it necessarily assisted in my understanding
or centering around the passage.
But it was nice.
It was relaxing to listen to a different accent read the Bible
than what I'm used to.
But there is one line in the story, and we're going to get to it.
It's going to take us a minute to get there,
but we're going to get to it.
And when you really look at it, it is like a megaphone
that is life-changing.
And I've read this story my whole life,
and it's never jumped out at me like that.
But it's huge, right?
So, okay, so let's read the passage.
We're going to dive in.
I'm going to pull it up here.
We're going to talk about what Jesus did to me this week,
and hopefully I can portray that in a way
to where He's going to change something in your life.
Oh, wait, I've got, I'm looking at my notes here.
I've got one more disclaimer.
This is maybe my one really strong theological stance
that I'll share tonight.
And this is it.
So, if you read the Bible,
anywhere in the Bible, anything in the Bible,
if it doesn't look like Jesus,
then you read it wrong.
Okay, I'm going to say it again.
If what you read in the Bible,
anywhere in the Bible,
doesn't look like Jesus,
then you read it wrong.
Okay, and the passage we're going to read tonight
is going to be easy to keep that in mind
because it is literally Jesus telling the story.
But try that, you know, when you read passages at home.
Try to read it and say,
did I read this in a way
that portrays the Jesus of the Gospels?
Right, and if you're not getting
a loving, kind, compassionate,
accepting, inclusive Jesus,
then you read it wrong.
Right, so if you read it
through the lens of Jesus,
it'll be life-changing,
no matter what you read, okay?
All right, here we go.
So, chapter 10, verse 25.
All right.
Just then, a lawyer stood up to test Jesus.
Teacher, he said,
what must I do to inherit eternal life?
And bam, right out of the gate,
we've got conflict, right? I love it.
So, this lawyer,
and when they say lawyer,
they're talking about a religious lawyer.
So, this guy knew the Old Testament,
like, backwards and forward.
And so, when it says, you know,
the lawyer stood up to test Jesus,
he really was, like, he knew the law.
The question is, what must I do
to inherit eternal life?
This guy knows the answer, right?
You ever have those bosses
or those teachers in school
where they ask you a question
and you can just see it on,
and you're kind of in a place,
like, if you don't know the answer,
like, what do I say, right?
I used to deliver drywall
when I lived in Denver, Colorado.
And we would take, I mean,
thousands of pieces of drywall
to new construction, hospitals,
high-rises,
and we had to stack them really neat
because the superintendent of the job,
the general contractor,
wanted a neat-looking site.
And sometimes he'd walk over
after we were finished stacking
and he'd go,
does that look good to you?
And I'd be like,
uh,
yeah, does that look good to you?
Uh, yes, sir.
Good to know.
And then he'd walk off, right?
And you're like, what?
What just happened?
So he knew the answer, right?
The lawyer knew the answer
before he asked the question.
So he knows the Old Testament
and he already knows the answer
to the real deal, right?
He's like, I'm gonna get this guy.
We're gonna see if he's the real deal, okay?
Verse 26.
He said to him,
and this is Jesus talking,
what is written in the law?
What do you read there?
Okay, Jesus knows.
This guy knows his stuff.
He's a religious lawyer.
He knows the Old Testament,
what it says.
And in a classic Jesus response,
he answers with another question, right?
Jesus is trying to trip him up
or even the disciples
who are just confused, right?
They ask questions.
He turns the situation around
to where in the case of this lawyer,
he's got to answer his own question
and in turn realize
the error of his worldview
or just continue on
in a state of confusion
or not understanding, right?
So verse 27.
So the lawyer answered.
He said,
with all your heart
and with all your soul
and with all your strength
and with all your mind
and your neighbor as yourself.
And he said to him,
this is Jesus,
you have given the right answer.
Do this and you will live, right?
The lawyer knows this answer as well.
He's quoting Deuteronomy and Leviticus,
the law.
This is like his thing, right?
He is the religious lawyer.
He knows the text from the Old Testament
You got it, man.
That's it.
So it doesn't stop there, right?
The lawyer doesn't take that.
So, you know, he's
he now has to justify himself, right?
So verse 29, it says,
but wanting to justify himself,
he asked Jesus,
and who is my neighbor?
Right?
So he knew the answer to this question.
Jesus knew he knew the answer to this question.
And so at this point,
Jesus was like, yeah, man, you got it.
Well, he's not good with that, right?
Because now he's like,
I just asked this silly question
and everybody knows I should know.
So he goes further.
Well, tell me who my neighbor is
because now he wants specifics.
He wants identifiers.
And how often do we,
in the church at large here in America,
do we not like the ambiguity of Jesus?
The ambiguous nature of his answers, right?
We want to, well,
tell us exactly what
we should and shouldn't do
and who we should and shouldn't love, right?
So this guy's calling him out,
says, well, who is my neighbor?
Because I want to know that
I'm still, you know,
loving the right people
and hating the right people, right?
Or hating the wrong people.
So he,
he quotes the law.
It was too ambiguous.
He left out identifiers.
So again, he tries to trip Jesus up,
you know, saying, well, who's my neighbor?
But in this context, right,
this time period in history,
the neighbor,
so to this lawyer,
a neighbor
was those in his tribe, right?
The ones that are close to him,
the ones that look like him,
the ones that believe like him
politically and religiously, right?
And so he's thinking, okay,
Jesus is one of us.
I'm asking him who our neighbor is.
Surely Jesus is about to justify
what I'm about to say
and what a neighbor was
and what a neighbor was not.
And then again,
in classic Jesus fashion,
a tale.
And we're going to start at
verse 30 in chapter 10.
Jesus replied,
a man was going down from Jerusalem
to Jericho
and fell into the hands of robbers
who stripped him,
beat him,
and went away,
leaving him half dead.
He was going down that road
and when he saw him,
he passed by on the other side.
So likewise,
a Levite,
when he came to the place and saw him,
passed by on the other side.
But
a Samaritan
while traveling came near him
and when he saw him,
he was moved with pity.
He went to him and bandaged his wounds,
having poured oil
and wine on them.
Then he put him on his own animal,
brought him to an inn
and took care of him.
The next day,
he took out two denarii,
gave them to the innkeeper
and said,
take care of him
and when I come back,
I will repay you
whatever more you spend.
Here it is.
Which of these three
do you think
was a neighbor
to the man who fell
into the hands of the robbers?
He said,
being the lawyer,
it's an interesting answer.
The one who showed him mercy.
Jesus said to him,
go and do likewise.
Right?
What a tale.
If there was ever a mic drop moment,
this is definitely one of them
for Jesus, right?
In all the stories.
Why?
Well,
let's go back in
and let's understand the context
of how the lawyer
would have heard this story.
Right?
So we've got characters in the story
and the location.
So the location being
a road from Jericho
or from Jerusalem to Jericho.
Right?
He's traveling from Jerusalem
to Jericho.
Well,
this was known
as about a 12,
15 mile.
It's not a road
like we would think,
right?
It's a mountain trail,
but it was known
to have looters
and robbers
and thieves
and who again,
just it was known
that if you were going
to travel that road,
there's a really
good possibility
you'd get robbed
or beaten.
So it was known
for this.
So he knew this.
He knew from Jerusalem
to Jericho,
this road,
bad stuff,
right?
And then we got four characters
in the story.
So we've got,
we've got
the priest
and we've got
and the priest here,
we can assume
that this is probably
a Jewish priest,
right?
It doesn't say that,
but I think it's safe
to assume this.
We've got a Levite
who was a temple helper
and assistant
to the priest,
right?
So he was a part
of the religious
framework
of the Jewish culture,
right?
So you got the priest,
you got the Levite,
then you've got
the generic man
on the side
of the road,
right?
The guy who was robbed,
He's not labeled.
We don't know his identity,
his social class,
his ethnicity.
And this is important
to the story.
This is on purpose.
And last we have
the Samaritan,
right?
It's known
in that culture
and that timeframe
in history
that Samaritans
hated the Jews
and vice versa,
the Jews hated
the Samaritans,
right?
There was a clash
of beliefs.
The Jews thought
the Samaritans
were unclean
and so didn't treat
them well
and in return,
the Samaritans
didn't treat
the Jews well.
So it was a,
you know,
classic cultural war
and they just,
they didn't like
each other.
And this is kind
of a main point
of a lot of
whenever the story
is told,
this is kind
of where they focus,
right?
You want to love
your enemies,
which is,
I mean,
I 100% agree.
But what I want to do
is go a little bit
deeper,
right?
So we should
love our enemies,
but does it
stop there?
Like,
how do we do it well
and where are we going
to go?
So let's keep going.
So this guy
gets robbed
and beaten,
right?
He's telling the
story,
right?
He's in the
culture.
Jesus is telling
the story to
him.
He knows what's
going on.
He knows the
location.
He understands
the context
of what Jesus
is saying
as the tale
continues
and the story
goes on.
So this guy
gets robbed
and beaten,
right?
So we're going
to have a
chance.
A priest
walks by
and the
lawyer may be
thinking,
okay,
the priest will
check on him,
right?
This Jewish
priest walking
from Jerusalem
to Jericho.
He's going to
check on him,
right?
Nope.
Okay,
well,
you know,
maybe the
lawyer is
thinking,
well,
he's probably
getting to,
he's got
religious
duties.
Maybe he
was traveling
with the
priest and
he was a
little bit
late so he
had to catch
up to him
to do
whatever they
were going
to do in
Jericho.
Maybe he's
justified.
He didn't
need to
stop.
He had to
get to the
priest.
Maybe he
didn't
need to
stop.
Maybe he
didn't
need to
stop.
He had
to get
to the
church
service
on time.
He had
to stop
by Starbucks
and get
a coffee
on his
way.
Then the
Samaritan
enters.
Now the
lawyer is
thinking,
okay,
I've heard
this joke
before.
The one
about the
priest,
the
lawyer is
like,
wait,
hang on,
this dude
stops?
We don't
like those
guys.
He's not
stopping.
That dude
is unclean.
He bandaged
him.
What?
He poured
oil and
wine on
his wounds.
You've got
to be
kidding me.
Then put
him on
his own
animal.
I found
out that
when it
says bandage
wounds,
the word
used there
is a
technical
medical
procedure.
I don't
know that
the Samaritan
was a
doctor,
maybe he
was,
but I
think the
point is
he didn't
just go
50%.
This Samaritan
was taking
care of
this
unidentified
person.
He wasn't
reading his
quote of
good deeds
or anything
like that.
Oil and
wine, he
was all
in.
In the
passage it
says he
was moved
with
compassion.
Compassion
is a
muddled
down
English
version of
what the
actual
word is.
He was
moved deep
down in
his gut.
Think about
those times
where you've
seen
somebody
that's just
hurting.
You just
feel it.
feel it
down in
your gut.
It's
gut
wrenching.
You hear
a story
of how
somebody
was
oppressed
or abused
and you're
like,
man,
gut
wrenching.
That's
a
good
story.
He
put him
on his
donkey.
We don't
know how
far he
went.
He paid
what some
suggest,
scholars,
people that
study this
full time,
paid two
months of
room and
board to
the inn
keeper.
Hang on.
The
lawyer is
just like,
what?
Two
months of
room and
board for
this guy?
We don't
even know
who this
guy is.
We don't
know if
this other
guy is
worth doing
all this
for.
You haven't
named who
this was.
This
lawyer is
tripping
out.
He's
like,
this
Samaritan
is an
enemy.
The enemy
is going
all out
for this
unidentified
man.
Absolutely
crazy.
At this
time in
the culture
of the
story,
this is
absurd,
preposterous,
right?
This is
where I want
to land
on something
that the
Samaritan
says.
He says,
take care
of him,
and when
I come
back,
I will
repay you
what it
cost.
This is
open-ended.
There's not
an ending
to this,
right?
I will
come back,
and I
will repay
you what
it cost
you.
The
Samaritan
could have
been
exploited.
This
could cost
more than
he already
had paid.
This
could cost
more than
he already
had paid.
Does it
look like
the insanity
of Jesus
and what
he's talking
about in
this story,
or does
it look
like
indifference?
Does your
love require
you to
give up
something?
Sit and
think about
this.
Ask these
questions.
Does your
love require
you to
give up
something?
Does your
love for
others hurt?
Does it
cost you?
You ever
felt exploited
for fully
loving?
Or did
you not
love enough
because you
could have
been taken
advantage of?
I think
the point of
what is
happening with
the Samaritan
is clear.
That's not
our concern.
We should
have so much
love that
we're not
concerned if
somebody takes
advantage of
it.
I'm not
saying you
go out
willy-nilly
and start
throwing
bills everywhere,
but when
you get
that gut
wrenching
down deep,
when you
see somebody
in need,
it doesn't
matter if
you get
exploited.
That's the
insanity of
love.
There are
three keys
to love.
The first
one being
this.
Love
intentionally
looks.
Okay?
Not love
sees,
right?
The priest
and the
Levi,
they saw.
They
crossed the
road and
kept on
going to
Jericho.
No.
The
insanity of
love says
that love
intentionally
is looking.
It doesn't
look for
moments in
time to
be insane.
Love is
looking for
moments in
time to
be insane.
Okay.
Number two.
Love
acts.
Insane
love is
called to
action when
it sees a
need.
Okay?
Bob Goff
has a book
and the title
of it is
brilliant.
It's called
Love Does.
That's exactly
right.
There's a story in
that particular
book where
he got bored
with Bible
study,
right?
You go and
learn a bunch
of facts.
He was
into doing.
Right?
He started a
Bible study
with some
friends.
They call it
Bible doing,
not Bible
study.
How can we
take the
words from
Jesus and
put them
into action?
The insanity
of love
is called
to action
when it
sees a
need.
Okay?
The third
key here.
Love
always shows
back up.
Just like
the Samaritan.
Hey,
here's two
months of
stay and
I'll come
back and
if I owe
more.
Right?
Let's not
even miss the
fact that
this guy
stayed overnight
with the
unidentified
person
overnight.
That's the
insanity of
love.
He didn't
know this
guy.
He was an
unidentified
person in
the story.
Right?
But this
guy stayed
overnight and
said I'll
come back.
I'll check
on him.
This isn't
the end.
Right?
And this
is something
that I really
want to
man
portray.
When we
separate
ourselves or
exclude people
or a
certain group,
Jesus
immediately
walks across
our line
that we've
created to
our enemy
and invites
us to join
him with
those that
we exclude.
Right?
Or our
enemy.
When we
separate
ourselves or
exclude people
or a
certain group,
Jesus
immediately
walks across
our line
to join
our enemies
and then he
looks and
invites us
to come
on over.
That's the
insanity of
love.
Right?
Because when
you exclude,
you become
the oppressor.
And that's
not Jesus.
When you
exclude,
you become
the oppressor
and that's
not Jesus.
Right?
So you
give ten
bags of
clothes to
charity.
Were those
clothes you
never wore
anymore?
Did you gain
from giving
them up?
Do you
have other
clothes to
wear?
That's not
insane
loving.
It's good.
You should,
yeah?
You should
give things
like that to
charity.
But that
shouldn't
stop.
Right?
That's not
the insanity
of
love.
It's
loving.
good, but
it's not
insane
loving.
It's not
the story
of the
good
Samaritan.
Right?
It's
stopping.
The
insanity of
love is
open-ended.
Right?
We
intentionally
are looking,
we're
acting,
and we're
showing
our
heart.
And
it's
just
insane.
Loving our
world is
living and
breathing and
hurting and
caring and
compassionate and
moving and
hard.
And it's
just insane.
And that's
what we're
called to
do.
Because
that's
Jesus.
Martin Luther
King Jr.
wrote a
sermon on
this passage
one day
we must
come to
see that
the whole
Jericho
road must
be
transformed so
that men and
women will
not be
constantly
robbed.
True
compassion is
more than
flinging a
coin to
a beggar.
It comes
to see
that an
edifice which
produces
beggars needs
restructuring.
The
insanity of
love is
about to
start back
at school,
right?
How about
that person
at school
that's down,
the one
that gets
verbally
abused,
walks alone,
sits alone,
maybe they
get beat up
and like the
story they're
left for
dead.
It takes
more than
picking up
their books
or saying
hi to
them in
the hallway.
How
can
true
compassion
be
Jesus?
Right
now in
this moment
in history,
the black
community is
the man on
the side of
the road,
they're
hurting.
The LGBTQ
community is
the man on
the side of
the road.
They're
hurting.
The
incarcerated,
the single
mom, the
single dad,
the ones
that have
lost
their job,
the hungry,
the lonely,
the depressed,
the confused,
the weak,
the poor,
the abused,
they're all
on the side
of the road
and it will
hurt and
it will
cost us
and it
will exploit
us.
But to
fully love
insanely,
we must
show up
because
Jesus who
loved
and
it
hurt
him and
he hung
on that
cross and
it was hard
but he
showed up and
it will
cost you
everything.
Insane
love
continually
shows up
and it's
open-ended.
Be their
bandage.
oil and
wine.
Love
insanely.
Be
Jesus.
Despite
everything.
Always
show back
up.
Love
insanely.
It gets
me every
time.
So I'm
going to
finish up
here and
I'm going to
read the
lyrics of
a chorus
to a song
that's about
to be
sung.
And it
kicks so
hard.
It
breaks your
bones.
Cut so
deep
hits
your
soul.
Tears
your skin
and makes
your blood
flow.
It's
better that
we know
that love
is hard.
Thanks for
listening.
Thank you,
Josh.
I see
lovers in
the streets
walking
without
a care
and they
wear it
out
loud like
the
sun.
And
they
wear it
out
loud like
the
sun.
And
they
wear it
out
loud like
the
sun.
And
they
wear it
out
loud like
the
sun.
And
they
wear it
out
loud like
the
sun.
And
they
wear it
out
loud like
the
sun.
And
they
wear it
out
loud like
the
sun.
And
they
wear it
out
loud like
the
sun.
And
if
they're
lucky,
they'll
get to
feel.
And
it kicks
so hard,
it breaks
your bones,
it cuts
so deep,
it hits
your soul,
and it
tests
your skin.
And
it makes
your blood
flow.
It's
better that
you
know
that
love
is
hard.
Love
takes
hostages
and gives
them pain,
gives
someone the
power to
hurt you
again and
again.
Ooh,
they
don't
care.
And
if
they're
lucky,
yeah,
they'll
get to
feel.
And
if
they're
lucky,
yeah,
they'll
get to
see.
And
if
they're
really,
really
lucky,
they'll
get to
feel.
And
if
they're
truly
blessed,
then
they'll
get to
believe.
And
you'll
be
lucky.
Ooh,
they
don't
care.
And
if
they're
really,
really
lucky,
they'll
get to
feel.
And
if
they're
truly
blessed,
yeah,
they'll
get to
feel.
And
if
they're
really,
really
lucky,
yeah,
they'll
get to
feel.
And
if
they're
truly
blessed,
yeah,
they'll
get to
feel.
And
if
they're
really,
really
lucky,
yeah,
they'll
get to
feel.
And
if
they're
truly
blessed,
yeah,
they'll
get to
feel.
And
if
they're
truly
blessed,
yeah,
they'll
get to
feel.
And
if
they're
really,
really
lucky,
yeah,
they'll
get to
feel.
And
if they
are truly
blessed,
yeah,
they'll
get to
and
love.
So,
yeah,
I know
that there
is a lot
of heavy
decision-making
beening
with rygard
to school
and work
and how
do we
keep going
in the
midst of
this
pandemic.
And
I know
that's
heavy.
So,
I hope
that this
time
there are
people that
you get to
process with.
If not,
please reach
out.
Yeah,
table TX,
we want to
be here
with you,
we want to
be a
sounding
board.
If there's
a way that
we can be
praying with
you this
week,
please let
us know.
If there's
something
tangible we
can provide,
please don't
hesitate to
reach out.
I pray
blessings
over all
of you.
I pray
for good
sleep.
Yeah,
and a good
week for all
of you.
In Jesus's
name,
amen.
Amen.
And
still
on this
side,
so
glad
that
I
ever
got a
chance
to
speak
you
today.
I will
be
speaking
today
to
you
in
the
same
way
that
I
did
in
the
last
talk
.
I
will
be
speaking
to
you
in
the
same
way
that
I
did
in
the
last
talk.
I
will
be
speaking
to
you
in
the
same
way
that
I
did
in
the
last
talk.
I
will
be
speaking
to
you
in
the
same
way
that
I
did
in
the
last
talk.
I
will
be
speaking
to
you
in
the
same
way
that
I
did
in
the
last
talk.
I
will
be
speaking
to
you
in
the
same
way
that
I
did
in
the
last
talk.
I
will
be
speaking
to
you
in
the
same
way
that
I
did
in
the
last
talk.
I
will
be
speaking
to
you
in
the
same
way
that
I
did
in
the
last
talk.
I
will
be
speaking
to
you
in
the
same
way
that
I
did
in
the
last
talk.
I
will
be
speaking
to
you
in
the
same
way
that